[Music]
the whole government is compromised
[Music]
it made it seem like our votes counted
but our votes wasn't worth a lit fart in
a world mitten
that seems like a good way to start the
movie
[Music]
my name is Andrew Callahan and I first
went viral online for interviewing
people on the road going to different
conventions conspiracy rallies music
festivals then in 2020 [ __ ] got super
serious protests police brutality that
[ __ ] is real it's Revolution time
pandemics remember that
so this is the story of the events that
led up to the January 6 Capital riot
as I saw them unfold
you may have gone to bed thinking this
election was headed one way and then you
woke up and saw things were different
and trending increasingly in another
Direction
[Music]
we saved the country we did it we did it
Joe Joe Biden is the apparent winner in
the state of Wisconsin no more mailing
Alex Mr mailbox so while it was true
that everyday people on the right were
being censored and kicked off social
media 98 of the media
it only just pushed them to all
platforms this is the sign for a boy
lover into Tighter and Tighter Echo
Chambers
they've been sacrificing children to
mole like animal human clones
to commune if you need anything you get
it there is no money
we were pitted against each other by
organizations and individuals who do not
care about us and are enriched from our
divisions
do you ever feel like you've gone too
far down the rabbit hole man
this is only the beginning
what's the end and there's no end